I'm going to make two rows of quarters
okay does this row have more quarters
does this row have more quarters or are
they the same say the same okay now
watch
now does this row have more quarters
does this row have more quarters or are
they the same
add some hands are cold that one has
more quarters why does that one have
more quarters see crank it strength down
because it's stretched out okay so how
many are in this room full five okay how
many are in this room 105 so are there
more in this room this room or are they
the same say the same yeah okay okay so
we have two sticks this stick longer is
this stick longer or are they the same
okay the same what about now is this
stick longer is this stick longer or are
they the same that stick is long ago the
stick is longer yeah can you tell me why
because you move to the oval so now it's
longer yeah okay tell me I'm going to
pour blue water into each of these cups
and you're going to have to tell me when
they're when they have the same amount
okay
okay tell me when this one is the same
they say the same those two are the same
now okay good I like it good okay now
watch this
we're going to take the blue water from
this glass I'm going to pour it into
this glass
now does this glass have more water does
this glass have more water or are they
the same hey you know a lot this one has
more water can you tell me why that's a
Toyota back that was higher than that
what right can you tell me just this
ball have more play-doh to this ball
have more play-doh or are they the same
after by paint that one has more yeah
let's make them let's try and make of
this the same you go to the same place
what about what about now and I say
they're the same now okay now watch now
does this one have more plate up does
this one have more play-doh or are they
the same that one hasn't bought today
that one has more play-doh can you tell
me why each must add one because that
one's smush how about
how about now does this one have more
play-doh does this one have more
play-doh or are they the same
si now they're the same why are they the
same load that would back up okay great
okay did we share the graham crackers
fair is this fair
yes yes you tell me why it's fair yeah
what did I do I have one up to a half is
that fair
no no how about now how that's fail now
that's fair why is that fair
you have two and I have two yeah